now let's turn our attention to the
story of a Russian businesswoman whose
treatment in Kuwait has led to calls for
sanctions to be imposed on the States
government marshal as arava
had worked for a decade in the oil-rich
Gulf state when she was accused of
embezzlement and she was sentenced to
ten years in prison with hard labor or
she has maintained her innocence
throughout and there's been a
high-profile international campaign to
free her which resulted in her release
from jail on bail after more than a year
but she's still not allowed to leave
Kuwait with her five-year-old son now
her supporters include Neil Bush the son
of former President George W Bush of
course and five members of the US
Congress have called for sanctions to be
imposed also on her side is the human
rights lawyer Shri Blair who founded the
Cherie Blair Foundation for women and
I'm delighted to say that she joins me
now thank you very much for being with
us this evening it's a very concerning
case this isn't it
Marcia has spent 470 days in a Cell
locked up with other women's is
sentenced to hard labor and just give us
an idea of exactly what she was accused
of doing well let me say first of all
this is not just about Marcia this is
actually about worrying signs that the
rule of law is being heavily undermined
in Kuwait and particularly that makes
foreign workers whether you're a
high-flying
executive which Marcia was or a migrant
domestic worker you're very very
vulnerable because we have a high and
and comfortably offed you maybe once you
are in the control of the state and
particularly imprisoned then obviously
you are particularly vulnerable I think
this is a particular issue for women as
well because of the attitude towards
women sadly is is not good in many of
these countries and there are big
questions about the legal system and how
Marcia has been treated because she was
essentially convicted largely as a
result of false documentation forged
documents everybody who has in in anyone
who's independent who has looked at the
case against marsian there are two cases
against Marcia but anyone who's looked
at the evidence
it's just astonished that any prosecutor
could have thought though this was a
case in the case that she was convicted
for example when she was where she was
accused of falsely claiming money from
the Kuwaiti Port Authority for services
rendered the truth was the documents
that were used to convict her were
forged and indeed the person who forged
them was subsequently charged with and
convicted himself of forgery and
sentenced to six months imprisonment for
that he actually absconded not to not to
do his sentence
so the other extraordinary thing about
that case was the civil courts in Kuwait
a separate system from the criminal
courts actually also considered that
case and in fact ordered the Kuwaiti
Port Authority to pay the money which
they said was Jew so you have one on the
one hand the civil court saying this
money is Jew and on the other hand a
prosecutor pursuing a case against all
reason even when there was evidence that
this was not a case at all and when the
defense was not allowed to put evidence
it's remarkable isn't it and it does beg
the question you know if she is
obviously innocent who's manipulating
the system who's behind this well
unfortunately I think this is a this is
an issue for anyone who's wanting to
work in a foreign country and anyone
who's thinking of making an investment
in in Kuwait because as part of this
actually is a commercial rivalry between
two firms one of which is the parent
company of the firm that Marcia worked
for and the other is a rival company who
are competing with each other for
American defense contracts hence the
interests of the Americans in this
particular case and one of those that
the business rival is very
well-connected politically and has been
able to manipulate the legal system to
try and damage their business rivals
yeah it's interesting you mentioned the
United States and we know that Neil Bush
is heavily involved in in the campaign
and and we and the West have always been
good Fred
with cue wait how have international
relations being damaged by this and and
how could they be damaged in the future
well it's very unfortunate you may know
that the Emir of Kuwait has been ill and
sadly I don't think he's really very
aware of what's been going on here and
but despite the efforts not just the
extraordinary is it's not just the
Americans it's not just even if you like
the British because my law firm only a
strategy a representing along with
British barristers it's also the the the
Russians too who are involved and it's
been raised by the Russian Foreign
Minister about the treatment of their
citizen and yet despite this there is
this blockage which lies firmly I think
with the Attorney General and the
prosecutors and sadly to some of the
judges in the case and that's why we
have fire proceedings in the United
Nations in Geneva the Human Rights
Commission complaining of her treatment
about complaining about her arbitrary
detention and also complaining to the
Special Rapporteur about the
Independence of the judges and he is
actually tweeted just recently his
concern about what has happened in this
case because if the rule of law is
manipulated in this way then actually no
one is is safe yeah how would you sum up
the human rights of curated America well
as I said I think at the moment foreign
workers in Kuwait are vulnerable because
it's not just Marcia while she was in
prison she came across a number of women
unjustly accused many of them were
migrant workers and only yesterday a
report came out again with the the UN
Rapporteur on human trafficking
highlighting what is essentially a slave
bazaar that is being carried on among
domestic workers in Kuwait using Apple
apps using Facebook and girls as young
as 16 being promoted for sale
essentially as as chattels that can be
used with advice saying you know don't
don't give them their passports you know
don't give them any holidays
you can imagine how vulnerable these
women are the domestic workers or far
away from home and where Marsha was in
prison she befriended a lot of them and
tried to help them with their case but
frankly within the legal system is
stacked against you even someone as
Marsha who's so well-connected now and
has so many people on her side no one
seems to be listening unfortunately the
international community is now listening
and are raising questions about what
exactly is going on in Kuwait good
excellent we're running short of time
but it won't have escaped your notice we
do have a general election on the way
and I'm just interested in getting your
thoughts about what it's like to be in
the spotlight when a campaign gets
underway
well I myself have been campaigning in
general elections since I was 16 which
sadly it's quite a long time ago now and
I elections or so that they're an
amazing thing because you could never
know what's going to happen and I think
this election particularly no one really
knows what's going to happen because it
all comes down to an individual and
their votes and I know lots of people
say oh you know what does it matter my
votes not going to count but actually
every vote does count I think
particularly now when everything is so
uncertain that people casting their
votes really can make a difference so I
don't envy those who are out canvassing
and traipsing the streets in December
it's not not the the best of fun i
remember the 97 election the sun always
seemed to be shining and there was a
sense of excitement and you know a good
change was coming I fear that that's not
going to be quite the feeling in the
dark days of December you've talked
about the campaigning work you do for
women and I'm interested in knowing what
the atmosphere is like now compared to
when you were in Downing Street because
it does seem to become very toxic
doesn't it it's become very poisonous
and a lot of it is directed at women and
women politicians I think this is it's
really shocking that so many good women
women MPs of all parties have helped the
pressure
on them and their families has led to
many of them standing down and maybe
it's it's a bit tied in with again the
internet and what is happening and how
that rather than bringing people
together seems to be polarizing people
so whether you have the internet being
used to sell domestic workers in Kuwait
or the inter internet being used to make
you know horrendous threats of violence
and and rape and just unpleasantness to
to women MPs it does appear as though
people think they can do and say things
on the internet with impunity and which
they would never dream of doing face to
face yeah it's a very different time
actually Blair it's been a pleasure
thank you very much indeed for coming in
speak to us thank you for having me you
see thank you